[Applaudissements]
alors je vous demande d'accueillir notre
candidat françois xavier bellamy merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers amis merci infiniment merci
infiniment
chers amis quelle incroyable aventure et
que de chemin parcouru qui nous a
conduits jusqu'à ce soir
ici à paris que de chemin parcouru pour
que vous soyez tous réunis et c'est
votre présence ce soir qui est le plus
grand signe de cet espoir dont laurent
vient de nous parler
legrand signe de cet espoir en train de
se lever
nous sommes ici nombreux dans un débat
que pourtant tout le monde disait joué
d'avancé
dans une élection que tout le monde nous
prédisait perdu d'avancé
vous êtes ici et c'est le signe que tout
commence c'est le signe que tout
commence ce soir pour les dix jours qui
viennent et pour les années qui
viendront
et je voudrais vous remercier d'être ici
et remercier en particulier ceux qui
nous accueillent ici serge geoffroy
chère brigitte en particulier tous nos
élus qui nous entourent je voudrais
remercier tous ceux qui sont ici avec
moi j'allais dire tous ceux qui sont ici
pour porter ensemble ce projet et que
nous défendons depuis trois mois
maintenant et je voudrais commencer par
dire je les ai déjà fait plusieurs fois
mais enfin il faut le dire encore et le
dire avec vous ce soir je voudrais
remercier et dire ma reconnaissance pour
sa confiance pour ce pari complètement
fou
je voudrais dire mon infinie
remerciements à laurent
laurent tu as fait un choix improbable
certains l'ont trouvé un probable qu'ils
se rassurent j'étais le premier d'entre
eux certains se sont posé des questions
qu'ils se rassurent je m'en suis posé
beaucoup et aujourd'hui nous sommes là
et j'espère que dans quelques jours avec
tout ce qui m'entoure
nous serons à la hauteur de ce paris qui
a été fait parce que nous avons besoin
de relever ensemble ce défi nous en
avons besoin pour notre famille
politique pour la droite et pour le
centre chaire hervé merci d'être là
merci d'être avec nous depuis le début
de cette campagne
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président du sénat même la
présidente de la région ile de france
cher gérard cher valérie c'est une joie
c'est une chance et un honneur pour moi
de savoir votre confiance et je voudrais
associer à vous tous nos élus tous les
parlementaires qui sont là tous les élus
si nombreux qu'ils sont venus de toute
la france
je voudrais vous dire à quel point je
sais qu'il ya de la presse ce soir mais
je vais vous faire une confidence quand
même je me pince un peu pour y croire et
je ne m'habitue toujours pas à entendre
mon nom scandé je remercie tout ce
qu'ils font mais je crois que ce qui est
en jeu c'est bien plus que ce nom ce qui
est non
[Applaudissements]
on fonce
au fond rassure toi rassure toi cher
hervé je suis bien loin de croire à tous
les éloges qui me sont faits et je sais
que ce qui compte maintenant pour moi je
le dis avec un peu de gravité c'est
devant l'ampleur de cet élan qui se
manifeste partout en france ce qui est
le plus important pour moi c'est de
pouvoir demain au cours des années qui
viendront et avec tous ceux qui
m'entourent mériter votre confiance je
ne l'est pas encore mériter il faut la
mériter demain et je sais et je sais que
au fond il y avait quelque chose
d'excessif dans la disproportion des
attaques que j'ai pu subir au début
quelque chose qui faisait que quand
j'entendais parler de moi dans la presse
j'avais du mal à me reconnaître
peut-être je me serais un peu détester
si je ne m'étais connu que par le récit
qu'on faisait de ma personnalité
en tous les cas je n'aurais pas voté
pour moi c'est probable mais mais c'est
la même mais c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui mais c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui quand je vous entends
témoigner de votre soutien avec des mots
qui sont si forts et quand j'entends ces
mots j'ai toujours envie de me retourner
pour savoir à qui on parle
et quand je me retourne pour savoir à
qui on parle je vois qu'ils sont
nombreux derrière ils sont nombreux
derrière ce sont mes colistiers c'est
toute cette équipe magnifique avec
laquelle nous portons cette aventure
depuis le début applaudissez lesdites
leur merci et je voudrais
et je voudrais remercier tout
particulièrement agnès et arnaud avec
lesquels depuis trois mois maintenant
nos sillonnant la france nous serons
encore demain matin à 7 heures dans le
tgv pour continuer notre travail pour
aller continuer de parler partout de
tenter de susciter la confiance
vous savez la politique a beaucoup perdu
son sens elle s'est beaucoup abîmé quand
elle est devenue la compétition
d'individualités qui ne cherchait que
leurs intérêts et bien moi je peux vous
en témoigner depuis le début de cette
campagne la politique c'est aussi et il
faut le dire parfois de grandes
histoires d'amitié et c'est ce qui s'est
nouée entre nous chers agnès cher arnaud
c'est ce que j'ai appris de vous qui
fait la force de ce que nous portons
ensemble et si parfois dans les médias
vous m'avez trouvé convaincant c'est que
j'étais seulement en train de dire ce qu
arnaud et agnès m'avait appris je leur
dois temps et je voudrais leur dire
merci
cette histoire c'est cette histoire
c'est aussi celle qui me lie évidemment
parce que nous sommes de ceux qui font
de la politique en étant enraciné à
cette ville où j'ai grandi à cette ville
où j'ai tout appris et nous sommes ce
soir dans la région ile de france chaire
valérie alors j'ai demandé et c'était un
choix qu'il a peut être étonné mais je
le remercie d'avoir accepté
j'ai demandé à françois s'il accepterait
de prendre la parole françois je
voudrais te dire ce soir
tout ce que je te dois tu m'as appris
que la politique n'était pas seulement
une affaire d'idées mais la rencontre
avec la complexité du réel
tu m'as appris que la politique n'était
pas seulement une affaire de déclamation
mais qu'elle se mesuraient d'abord aux
services qu'elle rend à ceux qui sont
sur le terrain les plus fragiles dans
une société
tu m'as appris que la politique est
forte quand elle s'inscrit dans une
histoire pour se projeter vers l'avenir
et je te dois au fond ce que j'essaye de
porter humblement dans cette campagne en
tentant d'être fidèle à ce que j'ai reçu
de toi merci françois je voudrais
remercier tous les amis de versailles
qui sont ici ce soir
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
évidemment en prenant la parole
c'était un discours de plus mais ce soir
est un peu particulier ça fait longtemps
qu'on parle déjà mais j'espère que vous
n'êtes pas fatigués vous n'êtes pas
fatigué c'est bien parce que maintenant
on va parler d'europe
on va parler de cette europe et de la
croisée des chemins à laquelle nous nous
trouvons nous sommes à un point de
bifurcation comme rarement dans notre
histoire un point de bifurcation pour l'
aventure de l'europe depuis le début de
cette campagne je le vois partout tous
les jours partout en france il entend
monter cette défiance
cette défiance envers l'union européenne
cette défiance envers la politique aussi
disons le cette défiance envers les élus
cette défiance envers la démocratie
je n'oublierai jamais tous ces
témoignages que j'ai entendu je
n'oublierai jamais cette conversation à
la fin d'un meeting dans un petit
restaurant nous nous étions réfugiés
avec l'équipe incroyable qui
m'accompagne depuis le début de cette
campagne cette conversation que nous
avons eue avec quelques agriculteurs qui
étaient à la table d'à côté avec
lesquels nous avons parlé et qui m'ont
dit en me regardant dans les yeux
c'est l'un d'entre eux qui parlait j'ai
50 ans je travaille comme un chien et je
vis comme un misérable je n'oublierai
jamais ces témoignages de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont le sentiment que
aujourd'hui nous faisons tout pour leur
compliquer la vie
eux qui pourtant créer de la valeur et
se battre pour créer de l'emploi
je n'oublierai jamais le témoignage de
ses salariés de ses ouvriers qui ont vu
partir des usines et qui ont le
sentiment que nous avons laissé
s'installer une concurrence qui les
fragilisent sans leur permettre
d'exprimer leur talent et leur savoir
faire face à tout cela je crois que
notre devoir n'est pas de rentrer dans
le schématisme qu'on voudrait nous
imposer et moi à cet agriculteur à ce
chef d'entreprise ce salarié cet ouvrier
qui me disent leur défiance
je ne me sens pas le droit
de lui répondre en le traitant de
populiste ce n'est pas en insultant
l'inquiétude que l'on peut la faire
reculer
nous ne combattrons pas
nous ne combattrons pas cette défiance
seulement en créant des anathèmes en
créant des fractures en opposant ceux
qui voudraient continuer d'aller de
l'avant dans un déni de réalité et ceux
qui voudraient revenir en arrière la
politique mérite tellement mieux et nous
avons le sentiment aujourd'hui que ce
débat qu'on voudrait nous imposer et
piégé dans une forme d' absurdité
monsieur macro on nous dit mon grand but
c'est de battre madame le pen madame le
pen nous dit mon grand but c'est de
battre monsieur macron et bien nous
notre seul but c'est de répondre aux
inquiétudes des français c'est de
résoudre les problèmes des français
emmanuel macron est allé en roumanie et
en roumanie il a dit je vais m'engager à
fond dans cette campagne moi je mets
toute mon énergie pour battre marine le
pen monsieur le président on aurait
tellement aimé que vous mettiez tout
votre énergie pour faire baisser la
dette de la france pour relancer leurs
activités pour relancer la compétitivité
pour résoudre la crise terroristes pour
maîtriser leurs frontières
voilà ce qui fait le coeur de la vie
politique et nous nous sommes dans cette
campagne
depuis trois mois maintenant au contact
des français pour les écouter avec
beaucoup d'humilité avec beaucoup de
simplicité et avec un projet à leur
proposer avec un espoir alors partagé
car nous croyons oui que l'europe peut
nous renforcer dans le monde qui se
dessine
oui chers joseph nous sommes héritiers
de cette europe de cette europe qui a vu
des pays européens qui s'était si
longtemps fait la guerre se rapprocher
pour se renforcer dans le monde qui se
destinait de cette europe qui a fait les
succès que nous avons pu connaître de
cette europe qui a fait la paix dont
nous héritons aujourd'hui nous savons
que cette europe aujourd'hui trop
souvent nous fragilise par la naïveté
dans laquelle elle est tombée mais nous
croyons que cette europe peut renforcer
nos pays et nous croyons qu'il est
nécessaire pour cela de la refonder en
profondeur de refonder l'europe pour
pouvoir rétablir la france voilà le
projet que nous faisons voilà l'espoir
que nous portons
refonder l'europe s'est refondée
l'europe c'est d'abord sortir de la
naïveté dans laquelle nous sommes
plongés sur le terrain économique et
commerciale aujourd'hui l'europe est le
dernier endroit au monde où l'on croit à
la fin de l'histoire
la fin de l'histoire si vous vous en
souvenez c'est ce concept inventé par un
philosophe américain dans les années 90
pardon je reviens à mon tropisme
professionnels ce concept inventé par un
philosophe américain qui s'appelait
francis fukuyama dans les années 90 il
parlait de la fin de l'histoire à partir
de ce simple constat le mur de berlin
est tombé disait fukuyama le mur de
berlin est tombé et personne ne s'est
enfui à l'est oui certains ont mis du
temps à s'en rendre compte c'est vrai en
france en particulier les enfants
c'était vrai le mur de berlin est tombé
et ainsi l' empire soviétique s'est
effondré et avec lui l'histoire a
tranché l'histoire a tranché en faveur
d'un modèle qui est celui de la
démocratie libérale et de l'économie de
marché est désormais c'est la fin de
l'histoire disait francis fukuyama
désormais toutes les barrières vont
s'abaisser toutes les frontières vont se
défaire toutes les identités vont se
diluer
et petit à petit de la figure du citoyen
préoccuper de l'avenir politique de son
pays particulier on verra arriver là
figure de l'individu consommateurs
auxquels une concurrence universel
apportera le meilleur produit au moindre
coût c'était le grand rêve de la fin de
l'histoire est bien le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ce rêve ne s'est
pas tout à fait réalisé les intérêts
particuliers n'ont pas disparu les
frontières ne se sont pas des fêtes les
identités ne sont pas diluer et nous
voyons que dans le monde par tous
exercent des pressions fortes
partout des stratégies affirmé
les etats unis ont une affirmation très
fortes de leurs intérêts économiques et
commerciaux la chine a une politique
très agressive sur le plan industriel et
nous nous nous avons une doctrine de la
concurrence parce que nous en sommes
restés à cette configuration apporter le
meilleur produit au moindre coût pour le
consommateur
il faut sortir
de cette naïveté le saviez-vous en
europe 20% du pib est constitué des
marchés publics et sur ses vents % de
pib constitué par les marchés publics
95% sont ouverts aux acteurs
internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à avoir
cette ouverture les américains ouvrent
leurs marchés qu'à 30%
les chinois à 0% la russie à 0%
comment est il possible comment accepter
plus longtemps qu'une entreprise
chinoise puisse venir prendre un marché
public en france et faire du profit en
france alors que jamais une entreprise
française ne pourra prendre un marché
public en chine même la plus compétitive
même la plus exceptionnelle comment
accepter que les règles soient faussés
non mes chers amis nous sommes d'une
famille qui croit à la liberté
nous croyons à la liberté nous croyons à
la force de cette liberté créatrice nous
croyons à la fécondité des échanges nous
ne croyons pas qu'il faut nous résigner
à ne plus être compétitif et comme
d'autres nous ne croyons pas qu'il
faille sans fermer entre quatre murs
pour mourir à petit feu pendant que le
monde continue d'avancer
nous croyons parce que nous sommes
patriotes nous croyons à la force de nos
entreprises à l'excellence de nos savoir
faire
nous croyons au génie de ses artisans de
ces ouvriers qui peuvent apporter au
monde ce que nous avons de meilleur à
lui proposé nous croyons à la force de
ses agriculteurs qui nous offre cette
alimentation sûre et saine eux comptent
16 de soupçonner alors qu'ils font la
confiance que nous pouvons avoir dans
ses produits par lesquels ils nous font
vivre alors qu'eux-mêmes vivent souvent
si mal eh bien je crois que
[Applaudissements]
à tous ceux qui travaillent dans notre
pays à tous ceux qui entreprennent nous
devons d'offrir les règles saines d'une
compétition équitable
nous croyons à la force de cette france
qui peut rayonner
mais la meilleure équipe du monde si
elle entre sur un terrain qui n'est pas
plat et dans lequel l' arbitre a été
précédemment corrompu la meilleure
équipe du monde ne peut que perdre la
partie
nous croyons à la compétition nous
croyons à la liberté mais nous voulons
que les règles soient les mêmes pour
tous et nous voulons enfin pouvoir
assurer une stricte réciprocité et nous
voulons dire à toutes les grandes
puissances du monde venez commercer avec
nous venez échanger avec nous mais à
condition que les règles soient les
mêmes pour tous et il est temps il est
temps de sortir de cette naïveté et il
est temps de faire en sorte de
construire une europe qui assume enfin
de défendre nos entreprises et nos
emplois qui assume enfin de défendre nos
agriculteurs qui assume enfin de choisir
de définir une vraie stratégie d'avenir
plutôt que de se laisser piéger par une
simple doctrine de la concurrence par
des normes et par des règles qui
asphyxient qui paralyse plutôt qu'elles
le stimulent ceux qui agissent qui
créent et qui entreprennent et qui
cultive voilà le défi qui est devant
nous et ceux des filles et ce défi il
est nécessaire pour redonner un
équilibre à la mondialisation ce défi il
est nécessaire pour remporter le grand
défi qui est devant nous celui de la
préservation de notre environnement
celui qui consistera à retrouver pour la
nature dont nous héritons cet équilibre
dont elle a besoin
car qu'est ce qui crée la crise
environnementale nous la résoudrons pas
si nous n'allons pas d'abord à la cause
certains cherchent absolument à
s'illustrer sur ce terrain alors ils en
font le premier chapitre de leur
programme et ils déclinent des solutions
qui sont au fond pas si nouvelle je
pense par exemple au projet de la
république en marche
le saviez vous le projet de la
république en marche commence par une
mesure
qui paraît forte mais qui finalement
nous rappelle que la gauche n'a pas tout
à fait disparu
cette mesure consiste à créer une banque
européenne du climat grandes crises
grands problèmes mais tout problème a
une solution cette solution c'est une
dépense donc grandes crises grandes
dépenses et le principe de la banque
européenne du climat c'est que le climat
va très mal alors il faut dépenser 1000
milliards d'euros on sait pas encore
pourquoi mais ce qui compte c'est la
dépense au fond
heureusement d'ailleurs que on se dit
parfois heureusement que ce gouvernement
n'est pas plus entendu en europe parce
que si la france prenait le leadership
sur ce sujet on pourrait lui faire
confiance pour les dépenses et les 1000
milliards d'euros n'y aurait aucun
problème mais on le voit bien
au fond il y as derrière tout cela un
manque de sérieux
un manque de prise en compte de ce qui
fait la cause de cette crise écologique
que nous déplorons ensemble et
s'attaquer à la cause de la crise
écologique
c'est en revenir précisément à cette
mondialisation débridée que nous avons
laissé se construire sous nos yeux
nous avons vécu trop longtemps dans une
mondialisation dans laquelle nous
pouvions penser que ça allait aller
s'accomplir une sorte de répartition des
tâches à l'échelle internationale un
terrorisme mondial on allait voir peu à
peu tôt de l'industrie se faire en asie
et en europe en ferait des services et
des loisirs ça ne pouvait pas
fonctionner ça a produit la catastrophe
économique et sociale que nous avons
connus mais ça produit aussi la
catastrophe écologique que nous
constatons aujourd'hui
le saviez vous
aujourd'hui on coupe du chêne dans les
forêts françaises on envoie ce chêne en
chine pour devenir du parquet ou du
mobilier et on le ramène en france pour
pouvoir être consommée
on mais nous en sommes les acteurs
cherchent à me on importe de l'agneau
est levée en nouvelle zélande selon
aucun des standards que nous imposons à
nos propres éleveurs et cet agneau qui
vient de nouvelle zélande est vendu dans
nos marchés et dans nos supermarchés
avant d'arriver dans votre assiette il a
fait plus de 18 mille kilomètres sans
que jamais on n'ait rien fait pour
décourager cette mondialisation devenue
folle tous ces produits qui viennent
chez nous et qui ont traversé la planète
avant d'arriver chez nous n'ont jamais
été freinés dans leur circulation
perpétuel et ensuite on va expliquer aux
salariés français qui a besoin de sa
voiture pour faire 10 km pour aller
travailler que c'est lui qui est
responsable de la crise écologique que
c'est lui qui est responsable de la
crise climatique
et bien non chers amis nous nous
préoccupons nous nous préoccupons de la
crise écologique et si nous voulons nous
préoccuper de transmettre à nos enfants
tu l'as dit cher laurent si nous voulons
nous préoccuper de transmettre aux
générations qui viendront ce dont nous
avons hérité nous devons leur
transmettre aussi un monde qui soit
encore vivables qu'il soit encore
habitable par l'homme et bien pour faire
ce monde encore vivables ce monde encore
respirable il faut tout simplement
rééquilibrer la mondialisation il faut
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons réapprendre à produire ce que
nous consommons
c'est tout le sens de cette barrière
écologique c'est tout le sens de cette
barrière écologique que nous voulons
placer aux frontières extérieures de
l'europe pour faire en sorte d'abord que
jamais nous n'autorisons à importer ce
que nous nous interdisons de produire
pour que jamais nous ne créions cette
concurrence déloyale qui fragilise ceux
qui travaillent en europe ceux qui
produisent en europe et pour faire en
sorte qu effectivement nos pulsions veut
donner de l'oxygène à nos entreprises et
à nos emplois rééquilibrer la
mondialisation c'est aussi ce dont nous
avons besoin dans la crise migratoire
qui se dessine si nous ne savons pas
remédié à notre impuissance la crise
migratoire chers amis elle n'est pas
passée
elle n'est pas comme le voudraient
certains commentateurs certains
observateurs certains contradicteurs
elle n'est pas de 2015 la crise
migratoire la crise migratoire
elle est devant nous la crise migratoire
elle n'a pas encore commencé l'explosion
l'explosion de la démographie du
continent africain représente l'un des
défis majeurs de notre avenir
et si nous ne savons pas mettre fin à
notre impuissance si nous ne savons pas
maîtriser nos frontières alors nous
allons continuer de produire du malheur
à grande échelle mais alors pour nos
sociétés qui sont déjà profondément
fracturé par une immigration que nous
n'avons pas su intégrer et accueillir
comme il l'aurait fallu
malheur aussi pour tous ces jeunes tu
l'as dit cher laurent pour tous ces
jeunes venus d'afrique auquel des
passeurs sans scrupules tendent le
miroir aux alouettes d'un eldorado
qu'ils ne trouveront pas as il arrive en
mettant le pied en europe
on nous fait de grandes leçons de morale
on nous parle de générosité et d'accueil
mais à tous ceux qui nous parlent de
générosité et d'accueil
je voudrais leur proposer cher valérie
devenir porte de la chapelle
je voudrais leur proposer de venir à
calais où nous étions il ya quelques
jours et qu'on nous dise si ça ressemble
à l'accueil qui ça ressemble à la
générosité
nous devons bien sûr ensemble construire
les conditions d'un partenariat qui
permettra de développer le continent
africain
parce que l'avenir des jeunes d'afrique
il est dans le développement de ces pays
et non pas dans le cynisme et dans
l'impuissance qui contribuerait à leur
faire croire que nous allons pouvoir les
accueillir et leur offrir cet avenir
qu'ils espèrent quand il ne trouve
qu'une impasse
oui il y à un principe simple nous
devons maîtriser nos frontières nous
devons faire en sorte qu'on ne puisse
s'établir en europe que si on a été
autorisé préalablement à entrer en
europe
et si nous n'arrivons pas à établir ce
principe
tant que nous n'arriverons pas à établir
ce principe il y aura toujours des
drames en mer méditerranée
le jour où il sera parfaitement certain
qu'on ne peut rentrer est resté en
europe que si on n'y a été d'abord
autorisé il n'y aura plus un seul mort
en mer méditerranée
mes chers amis pour relever l'importance
de ce défi il faut absolument une
stratégie européenne ne croyons pas un
seul instant que nos états seront plus
fort s'ils sont seuls nous ne croyons
pas contrairement au rassemblement
national que nous serons mieux capables
de faire face à l'ampleur de ce défi si
nous détruisons la coopération
européenne
le rassemblement national cher arnaud
mela longtemps redit à voter contre tout
ce qui pouvait permettre de renforcer
l'europe face à l'ampleur de cette tâche
le rassemblement avant le rassemblement
national a voté contre l'établissement
de contrôles systématiques à l'entrée
dans l'espace schengen à voter contre le
renforcement de frontex cette agence qui
lutte contre l'immigration illégale en
europe
le rassemblement national a voté contre
le fichier qui permet de connaître ceux
qui volent dans le ciel européen cher
frédéric et qui permet de garantir notre
sécurité
parce que c'était européen nous ne
sommes pas de ceux qui par idéologie
sont prêts à desservir les intérêts de
la france parce que une force
supplémentaire peut lui venir de
l'europe
nous sommes de ceux qui croient qu'il
faut être efficace ensemble et que
partout on selon ce principe de
subsidiarité qui a fait l'europe
partout nous pourrons être plus
efficaces ensemble alors il faut agir
ensemble et nous proposons le principe
d'une double frontières défendre
ensemble les frontières extérieures de
l'europe faire en sorte qu effectivement
nous puissions garantir que les demandes
d'asile et d'entrer sur le territoire
européen soit faite en dehors du
territoire de l'europe et défendre
simultanément le principe que chaque
pays doit pouvoir garder la maîtrise de
sa politique migratoire
parce que nous ne croyons pas
contrairement à monsieur macron que
l'europe doit consister à gérer notre
impuissance l'europe de monsieur macron
c'est celle qui voudrait imposer à
chaque état des quotas de migrants celle
qui considère comme le disait madame
belloubet récemment qu'on n'arrête pas
les flux migratoires qu'on ne peut que
se les répartir
eh bien nous nous disons qu'il ne s'agit
pas de gérer cette impuissance qui
causent encore une fois tant de drames
et tant de malheurs que la seule
politique qui va et elle consiste à
mettre fin à notre impuissance
nous croyons à l'accueil nous croyons à
la générosité
nous voulons pouvoir accueillir
mais nous ne voulons pas à subir nous
voulons pouvoir ouvrir la porte à celui
qui demande notre aide et qui a besoin
de notre aide
mais il est totalement différent
d'ouvrir la porte à celui qui a besoin
de votre aide
et le fait de ne plus avoir de porte
parce que vous n'avez plus du mur nous
voulons pouvoir accueillir
et c'est notre devoir pour l'avenir
c'est notre responsabilité parce qu'à la
fin ce qui est en jeu c'est aussi l'
équilibre de nos sociétés de ces
sociétés dont nous voyons quelles sont
en train de devenir une juxtaposition de
communautés
jérôme fourquet a écrit un livre que je
ne cesse de recommander l'archipel
français dans lequel ils montrent que la
france est en train de devenir cet
archipel de communauté qui s'éloignent
les unes des autres qui s'isole les unes
des autres qui ne se reconnaissent plus
de liens nous devons absolument relever
là aussi ce défi fondamental qu'est
l'unité de notre pays si nous ne voulons
pas que notre impuissance d'aujourd'hui
ne soit le ferment des conflits de
demain l'europe l'europe c'est la paix
dit on souvent
l'europe c'est la paix que nous devons à
nos aînés
mais cette paix est un miracle fragile
et nous le voyons bien évidemment il
n'est plus question aujourd'hui de
déclarer la guerre à l'allemagne
mais la guerre ressurgit sous d'autres
formes lorsque des innocents sont tués à
la terrasse des cafés dans des salles de
concert lorsque des personnes doivent
vivre sous protection militaire quand
elles vont pratiquer leur culte parce
qu'elles sont de confession juive
alors il y a bien évidemment le spectre
de la guerre qui ressurgit et nous
devons y faire face non pas pour le
déplorer mais pour montrer le courage
qui a été celui de nos aînés et pour
faire en sorte d'agir et face à ce défi
du terrorisme
face à ce défi de l'islam radical il
faudra bien sûr des réponses policières
il faudra bien sûr des réponses
judiciaires elles sont au coeur de notre
projet mais disons le très simplement
face à ce grand défi
la bataille ne sera gagné que si nous
sommes capables de dire de nouveau qui
nous sommes que si nous sommes capables
de partager de nouveau une culture
commune d'offrir de nouveaux une
civilisation en partage
le défi ne sera remportée que sur ce
grand ce premier ce décisif champ de
bataille qu'est celui de l'éducation de
la culture de la transmission
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui chères lydia tant de jeunes
grandissent en france qui ne se
reconnaissent pas de la france parce que
nous n'avons pas su leur dire ce que
signifiait rejoindre cette histoire
aujourd'hui tant de jeunes grandissent
en france et sont attirés par les
sirènes de l'islamisme intégriste mais
je crois que ce qui fait le succès de
l'islamisme intégriste dans tant de nos
quartiers c'est qu'il ne fait que
remplir le vide que nous avons laissé
prospérer derrière nous en ne sachant
pas dire qui nous sommes et tout ce dont
[Musique]
tout ce dont nous avons parlé ce soir
serait se résume finalement en une seule
affirmation une seule affirmation simple
il faut retrouver le sens de ce qu'est
l'europe il faut refonder l'europe
c'est-à-dire la reposer sur ses
fondations
l'europe ce ne sont pas d'abord des
administrations l'europe ce ne sont même
pas d'abord des traités l'europe ce
n'est pas d'abord un projet l'europe est
une civilisation et cette civilisation
cette civilisation c'est celle qu'il
faut pouvoir nommer car pendant trop
longtemps nous n'avons pas su la dir
nous n'avons pas su la reconnaître comme
notre nous n'avons pas su nous
reconnaître comme sien cette
civilisation c'est celle qui pourra
remplir ce vide que nous ne cessons de
constater il est temps de donner à tous
les jeunes qui grandissent en france
quelque chose à aimer il est temps de
leur donner la france a aimé ils
étendent leurs données l'europe en
héritage ils étendent leur redire qu'ils
sont les enfants d'une histoire qui nous
dépasse infiniment et qui nous lie les
uns aux autres qui nous relient les uns
aux autres l'europe c'est ce petit
miracle de la liberté qui naît dans les
cités de la grèce antique au vème siècle
avant jésus-christ lorsque des hommes
décident qu'il ne leur suffira plus
d'expliquer le monde par la mythologie
mais qu'il leur faut désormais la raison
la raison critique
c'est la naissance du logos c'est
c'est la naissance du logos qui devient
dialogos de cette pensée logique qui
devient dialogue qui devient
délibération qui devient démocratie
lorsque nous décidons que c'est ensemble
que nous parlerons de l'avenir que nous
voulons pour pouvoir écrire notre
histoire plutôt que de la subir
et à chaque fois que nous entretenons
cet héritage immémoriale dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée ou du sénat
comme dans le plus humble des conseils
municipaux
nous sommes les enfants de ces grecs qui
ont inventé la liberté à travers la
raison naissante l'europe
l'europe sait c'est le sens de cette
égalité devant la respublica devant la
chose de tout ce qui fait l'esprit
romain qui se déploie dans le monde
latin et qui fait de nous ce que nous
sommes les enfants d'un droit les
continuateurs de l'état ceux qui savent
qu'il n'ya pas de liberté s'il n'y a pas
de force publique et qu'il n'y a pas de
liberté s'il on obéit pas à l'autorité
des institutions qui nous relient les
uns aux autres
et puis l'europe c'est bien sûr pourquoi
ne pas le dire et pourquoi avoir tant
tardé à le dire pourquoi avoir eu tant
de peine à le nommer l'europe celle
aventures de cette civilisation
chrétienne nourrit d'une tradition
ancrée dans l'héritage de la
civilisation qui nous venaient du peuple
juif
l'europe c'est cette civilisation judéo
chrétienne qui a mûri peu à peu dans la
difficulté dans l'effort et le labeur le
sens de la dignité humaine de la dignité
absolue de la personne voilà ce qui a
fait l'europe
et on n'a pas besoin d'être chrétien
aujourd'hui pour savoir comme tu le
disais laurent que quand notre dame de
paris brûle nous sommes tous touchés au
plus profond de nous mêmes j'ai été
rencontrés quelques jours après l
incendie
le général qui commande la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris
il ne m'en voudra pas j'espère de faire
état de cette conversation
j'ai été lui dire simplement l'immense
reconnaissance que nous devons à tous
les hommes qu'il commandait ce soir là
lorsque la cathédrale notre dame de
paris a été sauvé pour les générations à
venir et nous parlions ensemble de cette
expérience inouïe
il me racontait que dans la nuit au
moment où les flammes menaçaient
d'atteindre les tours une décision
difficile avait dû être prise la
décision d'envoyer des hommes montés
dans ses tours d'envoyer des hommes
montés dans ses tours pour tenter
d'éteindre le feu qui menaçait
d'atteindre les cloches et qui aurait
fait s'effondrer la totalité de
l'édifice
ces hommes sont montés dans ses tours
comme d'autres pompiers en leur temps
dans les tours de new york n'ont pas
pour sauver les vies humaines
aucune vie humaine était en jeu ils sont
montés dans ses tours pour aller sauver
les pierres aucun d'entre eux n'a hésité
aucun d'entre eux n'a reculé ces hommes
sont montés dans ses tours et ils ont
risqué leur vie
ces applaudissements sens pour eux
ces hommes
ces hommes sont montés dans ses tours et
ils ont risqué leur vie pour ces pierres
parce que ces pierres sont quelque chose
de notre vie de la vie de notre société
de la vie de notre pays de la vie d'une
civilisation qui veut se transmettre
pour pouvoir continuer de relier les
hommes et les femmes qui s'en nourrir on
demain et bien moi je crois que au fond
dans cette expérience magnifique réside
toute notre espérance
oui nous ne sommes pas des communautés
isolées qui s'éloignent les unes des
autres
on n'a pas besoin d'être chrétien pour
se savoir lié par cet héritage commun
j'ai été tellement touché que toutes les
familles politiques que tous les
français quel qu'il soit est exprimé
leur émotion est eu le coeur retourné au
même instant au même moment devant cette
cathédrale qui brûlait il faut que nous
ayons la même émotion
la même inquiétude et la même espérance
devant cette civilisation dont nous
sommes les héritiers cette histoire si
belle si grande et si menacée
aujourd'hui si menacée par ses ennemis
de l'extérieur nous en parlions ensemble
nous en avons longtemps parlé tout au
long de cette campagne
mais si menacée surtout d'abord par nos
propres faiblesses par nos propres
démission par nos effondrement intérieur
oui c'est vrai au fond nous avons
renoncé à dire qui nous sommes et
lorsque je vous parlais de ce marché que
l'europe est aujourd'hui de ce marché
qui devrait être une force dans la
mondialisation mais qui semble n'être
parfois qu'une proie
eh bien nous parlons aussi peut-être un
peu de cette faiblesse que nous avons
laissé poindre dans nos esprits et dans
nos coeurs nous avons voulu devenir une
société d'individus consommateurs
additionnez les uns aux autres et
poursuivant chacun leurs propres calculs
on a voulu nous décrire comme étant
seulement une juxtaposition d'individus
qui ne cherchait que leur intérêt mais
nous sommes un pays nous sommes une
civilisation est ce que montrer ses
sapeurs pompiers ce que montrent tous
ceux qui s'engagent aujourd'hui
pour dire leur solidarité ce qu'ont
montré d'une façon si grande et si forte
cédric de pierrepont et alain bertrand
cello c'est que nous sommes liés les 29e
cédric de pierre pons et alain berton de
celle au ne connaissait pas les
personnes qu'ils allaient délivrer il ne
les avait jamais rencontré mais ils ont
accepté toutes leurs vies de se former
et d'attendre la plus extrême des
compétences la plus grande des exigences
pour allait être la main qui se tend au
milieu du plus grand des dangers pour
que jamais il ne soit dit que le lien
qui nous unit n'existe plus pour que
malgré l'adversité ils soient fermement
établi que nous sommes obligés les uns
envers les autres par ceux qui nous
précèdent et nous dépasse infiniment le
sens de cette commune humanité qui mûrit
dans la civilité d'une civilisation
voilà ce qui nous relie voilà ce qui
fait nos racines
voilà ce qui peut construire notre
avenir voilà ce qui peut refaire notre
société voilà ce qui peut refonder
l'europe et pouvoir rétablir la france
oui chers amis
oui chers amis nous ne sommes pas que
des individus consommateurs et le but de
notre existence n'est pas de pouvoir
pousser des caddies le dimanche dans les
rayons d'un supermarché
oui chers amis notre vie notre vie passe
par le travail parce que le travail
n'est pas seulement pour nous l'occasion
de gagner notre vie dans la pénibilité
dont on nous parle trop souvent le
travail est pour nous l'occasion de nous
réaliser en produisant une oeuvre
commune qui pourra être fait contre pour
d'autres que nous oui oui nous croyons
c'est vrai qu'il ne faut pas donner dans
notre vie la totalité de nos existences
à ceux qui se comptait se calcule oui il
y a des choses qui ne se marchande pas
oui il y a des choses dont on ne fait
pas commerce oui on ne loue pas le
ventre d'une femme
oui
et oui disons le très simplement ceci
est aussi un immense défi européen non
pas parce que nous demanderions à
l'europe de définir notre modèle de
société pour demain mais parce que si
l'europe est une civilisation pour être
fidèle à elle-même elle doit porter dans
le monde
la voix claire et forte de ceux qui
savent ce qu'est l'humain et que
l'humain est infiniment précieux que
l'humain mérite d'être transmis dans sa
valeur infinie oui nous sommes nous
sommes sans doute la première génération
dans l'histoire qui aura à faire face à
ce défi fondamental ce défi de préserver
et de transmettre la condition humaine
elle-même
aujourd'hui nous le voyons bien nous
avons à faire face à des tentations
multiples la chine vient d'annoncer il y
a quelques semaines tout juste qu'elle
avait donné naissance aux deux premiers
bébés génétiquement modifiés et oui pour
lutter contre le génie sme qui menace
d'atteindre nos sociétés qui menace de
transformer nos propres records en ce
champ de bataille supplémentaire pour
l'exigence de performance et de
compétition perpétuelle oui nous aurons
besoin que l'europe soit fidèle à elle
même pour faire entendre cette voix dans
le monde
et oui nous aurons besoin que l'europe
puisse dire qu'effectivement cette
exigence de solidarité absolue qui fait
que nous sommes capables de nous donner
totalement pour la vie d'autrui
lorsqu'elle est menacée lorsqu'elle est
fragilisée oui cette exigence elle fait
que nous regardons tout vie comme étant
digne d'être vécue
même la vie malade même la vie
souffrante même la vie vieillissante
car oui nos vies ne sont pas faites de
performance et de compétition seulement
elles sont faites aussi elles sont
faites aussi de ses fragilités de ces
vulnérabilités de ses dépendances qui
sont comme les brèches qui ouvre notre
relation aux autres
nous avons tous nous sommes tous nous
serons tous dépendants des autres et
nous n'avons pas le droit de dire d'un
homme que parce qu'il est dépendant il
ne mérite plus de vivre cherchant à toi
qui a porté ce défi fondamental
voilà chers amis le défi qui est devant
nous et voilà pourquoi nous n'avons pas
les le droit de laisser ce débat
européen se réduire à ce jeu caricatural
qu'on voudrait nous présentez nous n'en
pouvons plus des élections triste nous
n'en pouvons plus de voter contre
votez contre marine le pen voté contre
monsieur macro non nous ne voulons pas
de ce cauchemar
nous ne voulons pas que la france traite
piégé dans un éternel second tour
nous voulons voter pour nous voulons
voter pour l'europe que nous voulons
pour l'europe que nous aimons pour la
france que nous aimons
alors ce soir
ce soir il faut nous montrer fidèle à ce
que notre famille politique à ce que la
droite et le centre pierre laurent cher
hervé doivent porter de singulier dans
le débat politique pour aujourd'hui et
pour demain
oui nous sommes de ceux qui n'ont pas
renié leurs convictions et quant à
monsieur le premier ministre vous vous
en prenez ne lui est pas ne lui est pas
non nous voulons vivre le débat
politique avec le sens de la
contradiction claire et forte il y en a
eu ni si c'est sûr il y en a eu ni si
lorsqu'on insulte des gens lorsqu'on
insulte une famille politique tout
entière parce qu'elle n'a eu d'autre
tort que de rester fidèle à ses
convictions et à ses électeurs alors je
crois qu'on se discrédite
nous avons nous avons le devoir de
relever la tête
nous avons le devoir de relever la tête
à l'occasion de cette élection
européenne nous le devons non pas
seulement à la droite et au centre non
pas seulement à notre famille politique
nous le devons à la france parce que
c'est la france qui a besoin de sortir
de ce désespoir dans lequel on voudrait
l'enfermer de ce désespoir dans lequel
on voudrait la piéger de ce désespoir
qui est fait de ce faux débat dans
lequel on voudrait réduire toute la vie
politique de demain devant tous ces
grands enjeux
devant ces questions magnifique devancé
défi inouï
comment serait-il possible que le coeur
de la politique se réduisent à la
question de savoir qui va gagner de
monsieur maquereau ou de madame le pen
le coeur de la politique c'est de parler
de projet c'est de parler de concret
c'est de parler du fond le coeur de
notre défi c'est de réconcilier la
politique avec le réel de réconcilier la
politique avec la vie des gens de
réconcilier apolitique avec le terrain
de redonner du sens à la politique
ne vous laissez pas voler cette élection
ne vous laissez pas voler vos
convictions
ne vous laissez pas voler ce débat sur
l'europe
l'avenir de la france c'est cela qui est
en jeu alors oui c'est vrai beaucoup
doutent encore et si vous êtes convaincu
pendant les dix jours qui viennent il va
falloir être convaincant oui beaucoup
doutent encore beaucoup se disent que la
politique les a déçus que la politique
les a trahis
beaucoup se disent disons le très
simplement que notre famille politique
parfois les a déçus qu'elle a parfois
donné le sentiment qu'elle les avait
trahis et beaucoup vous diront en
agitant les peurs beaucoup vous diront
par un assaut de cynisme qu'il n'y a
plus d'espoir qu'il ne faut plus y
croire que ce sera toujours la même
chose
eh bien nous nous disons d'abord que
nous n'avons pas à rougir de notre
héritage et moi je voudrais dire avec
vous je voudrais dire avec vous merci à
toutes les grandes figures de notre
famille politique qui sont ici je
voudrais remercier monsieur le premier
ministre edouard balladur de votre
présence ce soir
lemercier nos anciens ministres michèle
alliot-marie remercier nos
parlementaires européens remercier
franck proust et à travers lui tous ceux
qui ont porté nos couleurs au parlement
européen au cours des dernières années
et je voudrais que nous puissions dire
aussi parce que c'est vrai la critique
est souvent facile mais que la
persévérance a été bien difficile au
cours des dernières années
je voudrais que nous puissions dire un
immense merci à tous nos parlementaires
qui sont ici ce soir avec nous ils ont
été le visage de cette persévérance ils
n'ont pas abandonné
ils n'ont pas renoncé ils ont porté
notre voix ils ont porté notre liberté
et je voudrais remercier à travers eux
je voudrais remercier christian jacob et
bruno retailleau de leur confiance de
leur amitié remercier annie genevard de
sa fidélité
nous croyons à la fidélité et nous ne
croyons pas qu'il faille opposé tu l'as
dit laurent l'ancien monde au nouveau
monde
il n'y a rien de bon dans ce qui est
nouveau que ce qui est fidèle à ce qui
était reçue d'une transmission qui nous
précède il n'y a rien de bon pour
l'avenir que ce qui nous vient de notre
héritage commun et il ne pourra y avoir
de sève pour pouvoir construire notre
avenir que si nous savons quelles sont
nos racines et si nous savons les nommer
je voudrais vous dire à quel point nous
avons besoin de vous et pour terminer je
voudrais dire un mot tout particulier à
tous les jeunes qui sont ici et ils sont
nombreux ce soir
me viennent me viennent à l'esprit
me viennent à l'esprit ces mots de
bernanos dans le chemin de la croix des
âmes c'était au plus noires de la
seconde guerre mondiale et bernanos
écrivait au jeune français jeunes
français qui métier hier encore que
l'enfance de mon pays une crise sans
précédent vous pousse désormais au
premier rang
amin j'ai entrepris de vous parler comme
à des hommes entre le désastre et nous
il n'ya plus que votre jeune honneur
nous sommes les enfants d'une même des
fêtes mais vous seul pouvez la regarder
d'un regard innocent tenez bon tenez
ferme
soyez fidèles tenez bon tenez ferme
si vous êtes fidèles chers amis jeunes
français alors il restera à ses donneurs
au pays à ses donneurs pour vous et à
ses donneurs pour nous chers jeunes qui
est ici ce soir
chers amis nous avons besoin de vous
pour reconstruire une famille politique
qui puisse porter au tout ce en quoi
nous croyons pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui a le sens de la
transmission pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui croit à la force
de la france mais qui croit que la force
de la france suppose qu'elle se libère
des freins qu'elle s'impose à elle même
pour reconstruire cette famille
politique qui mettra fin à la menace
terroriste pour reconstruire cette
famille politique qui offrira demain un
nouvel espoir à la france nous avons
besoin de vous chers amis nous sommes
les enfants de cette histoire magnifique
nous sommes les enfants de l'idéalisme
de platon de la juste mesure d'aristote
nous sommes les enfants de cicéron et de
marc aurèle cet empereur qui savait que
chaque matin c'est pour faire oeuvre
d'hommes qu'on se réveille
nous sommes les enfants des paysans qui
ont défriché l'europe nous sommes les
enfants des chevaliers qui ont inventé
le code de l'honneur nous sommes les
enfants de cet héritage des lumières qui
a développé la raison critique
nous sommes les enfants de ce2 14
et des résistants de 40 qui ont fait
notre liberté d'aujourd'hui au prix de
leur vie
nous devons nous montrer à la hauteur de
cette histoire et nous serons à la
hauteur de cette histoire et c'est
exactement ce qui se joue dans les dix
jours qui viennent je voudrais dans les
années qui viendront avec tous mes
colistiers au parlement européen pouvoir
être votre voix
mais pendant les dix jours qui viennent
il faut que vous soyez notre voie car
vous seul pouvez faire cette victoire
dont nous avons tellement besoin
vous seul vous n'êtes pas venus écouter
vous êtes venus agir
vous n'êtes pas venus écouter vous êtes
venu vous engager et dans dix jours
cette victoire sera la vôtre on refonde
l europe et pour rétablir la france
merci de tout coeur merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]